watching an episode of Buck Rogers from
1979 TWiki is missing the subplot was
transferring 10 million tons of frozen
oxygen from space to the North Pole
where it would melt and replenish the
oxygen depleted atmosphere of the planet
the quote space burg has to hit a window
in our atmosphere exactly or be ignited
by friction and scorch a third to a half
of the planet my questions one what an
exchanges
I know what an injection of frozen
oxygen or anything from space help earth
and B could a space burg of oxygen
scorch the earth okay so so the help of
things yeah first burg actually German
for a mountain so yes be a oxygen berg
yeah
space berg would be a mountain of space
if you want to realize ly analyze it I
will let whoever rub Buck Rogers know
that they have made some terrible words
mistake iceberg is a properly named
object yeah yeah those Mountain if it's
an iceberg yeah so the here's the thing
earth it has no shortage of oxygen at
the moment we just have too much carbon
dioxide we have a shortage of oxygen if
you wanted to just simply add oxygen to
the atmosphere what will happen is fires
that are ignited will not burn out as
easily as they might today oh because
oxygen feeds fires right right so let's
say we have twice as much oxygen as we
do today and lightning strikes the leaf
and ordinarily the leaf would just sort
of ignite but then fizzle away not with
more oxygen in the atmosphere it would
totally come to flames it would catch to
another leaf and you would burn forests
like it was nobody's this is so space
berg native oxygen is what you would
describe as a very bad I think I'd be a
bad idea unless we're actually for some
reason losing our oxygen and you have to
replenish right and what we're gaining
is carbon that's like we're not losing
oxygen this to to correct now we have
plenty of water we don't need to bring
oxygen from space water is what
chemically hydrogen enough the h2o yeah
oh you just what's you break the ice for
the hydrogen away from the oxygen you
got free oxygen right you don't do a
space please easy yeah so maybe the Buck
Rogers writers didn't know
this yeah cause oxygen itself is not
flammable it only allows other things to
burn right so when they say don't smoke
in your oxygen tanks you're not going to
burn in the oxygen tank the oxygen tank
is going to burn you right okay you
light a cigarette the cigarette burns
instantly and then the flame the spark
hits your finger then it burns your skin
that burns your clothes okay you would
explode yeah this is how we lost three
out of three astronauts at Apollo one oh
really is a pure oxygen atmosphere
inside their capsule on the launch pad
on a practice launch pad as they were
testing communications and other things
and it was sparked outside the
spacecraft triggered and everything
burned inside a spacecraft okay but they
didn't like light a cigarette they were
noting yeah well you said that's what
happened and then you will didn't it but
the regular it's a spark it's good all
right well yeah